ما هو الشيء المشترك بين هذا الدب من ولاية كونيتيكت
وبين لص نصف مخبوز في
مخبز في فانكوفر، مولع بالحلويات
للكعك، تم القبض على الرجل على
كاميرا المراقبة وهو يركل باب
مخبز يسمى حلو، وهو شيء تعرفه
أنه اقتحام كندي للغاية  لقد كان
محترمًا حقًا وقام بجولة في المتجر
واستخدم الحمام وجلس للراحة
ثم حصل على ممسحة ودلو
وحاول تنظيف الفوضى التي أحدثها
وكسر الزجاج كيف كان
كممسحة كما تعلم أنه لم يفعل ذلك  أفضل
عمل يمكن أن تقدمه له مثل هذا
المجهود، هذا الدب في أفون كونيتيكت
حصل أيضًا على تقدير للجهد،
دخلت المرآب في مخبز يُدعى
Taste بواسطة Spellbound بينما كانت الشاحنة بداخلها
محملة بالأشياء الجيدة، كيف تم
تنبيهك لأول مرة إلى الدب
من قبل أحد موظفيي يصدرون أصواتًا لم
أسمعها أبدًا تصدرها قبل أن تقوم
المالكة ميريام ستيفنز وأحد
موظفيها بالركض حول
المبنى لمعرفة ما إذا كان الدب قد اختفى،
ثم استداروا عند رؤيتها،
وسحب الدب  حاوية بالخارج محملة
بـ 60 كعكة كب كيك، أعتقد بصراحة أنها
أكلت الورقة مع الكب كيك وهي
تلتقطها فقط 60 كب كيك
للدب،
أخذ الرجل في
فانكوفر ستة كعكات الشوكولاتة والشمبانيا، كما استخدم
الهاتف الخلوي الخاص بالمتجر لالتقاط العديد من صور السيلفي  ترتدي
نظارة شمسية برتقالية، هل ستوجه
اتهامات ضد الرجل الذي طلبنا من
الشرطة ألا يهتموا حقًا بلص
الكب كيك الستة وكأننا لسنا
منزعجين من ذلك ولم يزعج أي شيء
الدب حتى توجه أحد الموظفين نحوها
وأطلق البوق  تم القبض على الدب لاحقًا
في فخ برميل ثم تم إطلاقه على
مسافة بعيدة واستفاد كلا المخبزين
من Capers من خلال بيع كعكات الكوب
المزينة بنظارات شمسية برتقالية
والدببة فقط فكر في
الإمكانات الإعلانية التي حلمنا بها
ولا يمكن أن يتحمل هذا الإعلان أن يكون بدون كب كيك.
صرخة، ستصرخين، هل يمكنك أن ترى من يحب
كعكاتنا بما يكفي ليأكل 60 قطعة منها؟ لقد
ترك الدب الفوضى خلفه، لكن
الرجل الذي ينظف بالممسحة يأخذ
الكعكة، ناهيك عن الكعك الستة
لقناة سي إن إن نيويورك